bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire pendant deux mois
j'ai fait cette émission depuis chez moi
confinement t'oblige ça a été l'occasion
de vous montrer mes tableaux préférés et
de recevoir par skype
beaucoup d'invités que j'ai pu
interroger sur quantité de sujets d un
pensée du confinement ou conséquences
économiques de l'arrêt de toute activité
nous avons pu explorer tous les méandres
de la crise du comique 19 et comme ça
n'est peut-être pas terminée qu'il
pourrait bien y avoir une deuxième vague
voici une sorte de best-of de quoi
réfléchir pendant l'été
[Musique]
on se suit ac l'om et ce dès le début
nous a dit tester tester tester tester
on sait que aussi bien à taïwan car
mongongu contestent systématiquement dès
que vous sortez qu'on vous qu'on vous
rencontrent au lieu de vous verbaliser
comme en france on vous teste et comme
vous l'avez dit ensuite on suit ont fait
le chemin inverse pour savoir qui si
vous avez été contacté
si vous avez si vous êtes positif on
cherche tous les gens que vous avez
rencontrés et on vous isole dans un
hôtel notamment
on se voit bien que ça a inspiré le
président mais là on nous parle de
tester uniquement les gens qui ont des
symptômes
ce qui veut dire que tous les les gens
ainsi à 5 thomas tic ne seront pas
testés
c'est à dire que moi vous et moi quand
nous allons sortir si nous n'avons pas
de symptômes nous ne serons pas testé à
quoi ça sert alors il ya deux
interprétations possibles soit ne nous
nous trompons de stratégie ce qui serait
quand même un petit peu étonnant c'est à
dire que nous considérons que cette
stratégie à la coréenne n'est pas
l'année n'est pas une stratégie optimale
et donc que l'on peut se passer d'avoir
une inter massif à la fois sur les
personnes qui ont été en contact avec le
virus mais d'ailleurs parce que ça n'a
pas été abordée autant le confinement
individualisé parce qu'on sort d'un
confinement général pour aller vers un
confinement qui sera individualisé à
salah bon ça ça a été abordé par le
président donc ça ce que nous appelons
ce groupe b qu'il faut vraiment
identifier très tôt tester très tôt
confinés dans des conditions très
strictes
et encore une fois suivre tous les cas
contact des derniers jours ça a été
abordé ce qui n'a pas été abordée c'est
encore une fois de l'identification de
la partie de la population qui est
immunisée or encore une fois c'est une
puisque ce que l'on recherche c'est
l'immunité de groupe 1 certains pays
comme l'angleterre et les états unis ont
cru que finalement limité gros plus vite
on on l'avait et plus vite on en serait
sorti sauf qu'évidemment c'est ça a des
conséquences sanitaires en terme de
mortalité qui sont absolument
insoutenable fait exploser votre système
sanitaire immédiatement donc ça c'est
park c'est pas la bonne stratégie mais
on reste il faut que les français
comprennent bien c'est parce que c'est
quand même assez simple
que ce que l'on va faire jusqu'à
l'arrivée d'un vaccin qui permettra
d'avoir cette immunité groupe est donc
de faire de ce risque extrême un risque
facile à endiguer
mais il va falloir que l'on fasse
augmenter cette ce groupe de personnes
immunisées parce qu'il va forcément
augmenter puisque le virus est toujours
présent mais qui est donc de façon de
façon contrôlée avec des cas graves qui
seront traités à l'hôpital mais un
certain nombre de cas qui seront qui
seront immunisés qui pourront retrouver
à une vie normale donc c'est là c'est la
maîtrise de la chaîne de contagion à
partir du moment où vous n'êtes pas sur
une spirale épidémique
1 la spirale épidémique elle est
exponentielle c'est à dire que quand
vous avez une personne contaminée
ces trois qui sont ensuite contaminé
puis ces neuf puis c'est 80 places et
200 et qu'elle puisse et puis vous
arrivez à 1000 donc ça va très vite
donc une fois qu'on est sorti de cette
spirale là il faut s'assurer de ne plus
y rentrer et c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
phase jusqu'à jusqu'à la vaccination ce
qui m'a beaucoup étonné vous avez une
bizarre c'est que le président de la
république a déclaré nous n'allons pas
testé toutes les françaises et tous les
français ça n'aurait aucun sens
or c'est exactement ce que préconise le
ms depuis le début c'est ce que font les
pays qui ont mieux réussi que nous il
teste justement tous leurs
ressortissants
et ça a l'air d'avoir du sens alors
qu'est ce qui a fait mal compris alors
je pense c'était la deuxième option j'ai
parlé que de la pâle deuxième option
l'interprétation qu'on peut avoir à
partie moment on se dit on sait que la
bonne stratégie c'est celle qui ont mis
en place les allemands et les coréens
mais nous sommes nous avons une
stratégie qui est guidé par la pénurie
c'est à dire que nous ne sommes pas en
mesure puisque le chef de l'état a pas
fait allusion à nos capacités de pouvoir
réaliser ces tests sérologiques donc
malheureusement on peut craindre mais
moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux plutôt
avoir imposé la bonne stratégie proposée
la bonne stratégie et faire en sorte que
les lettres qu'il ya un espèce de plan
marshall pour qu'on arrive avec
l'arsenal suffisant
pour mettre en place cette stratégie
plutôt que d'abandonner un petit peu par
pénurie de moyens nous sommes quand même
la sixième puissance du monde nous
sommes une des pluies une d1 des pays
sur le plan pharmaceutiques les plus les
plus expérimentés avec d'énormes
capacités
donc elle alla bien sûr il faut tester
massivement dès les premiers signes avec
des tests pcr et testé massivement la
population pour savoir véritable quelle
est la part de cette population est
immunisée c'est ce qu'ont fait les
autres qui ont réussi l une des grandes
différences entre l'allemagne et la
france c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup de
tests 1 il avait beaucoup plus de tests
toute personne présentant des symptômes
même bénin a été testée semble-t-il
gratuitement à la fois dans les hôpitaux
dans les cabinets médicaux mais aussi on
l'a vu sur les parkings
oui bien sûr l'allemagne si vous voulez
pas d'emblée deux mesures préventives ou
quasiment d'emblée de mesures
préventives la fermeture des frontières
et les tests au tiff
ce sont des mesures de bon sens ce sont
des mesures qui n'étaient pas là pour le
coup c'était pas contre les voisins
européens
mais à partir du moment où l'autriche
est très contaminée la france est très
contaminée ils étaient tous temps normal
que l'allemagne songe à fermer ses
frontières et d'autre part l'allemagne a
aussi fait exactement comme la corée
elle est idée de thé rapidement et
beaucoup de manière à avoir une idée de
qui est véritablement infectés et de
fait ces sacs qui a aidé à ce que l'on
n'aille pas sur un confinement total
mais qu'on est plutôt une une mise en
place de distanciation sociale renforcée
alors pour faire des tests il fallait
être capable d'en fabriquer l'allemagne
où le sait
et puissante industrie pharmaceutique
mais la france aussi pourquoi est ce que
l'allemagne a pu fabriquer des tests et
bas nous mais vous savez avant de
fabriquer des tests l'allemagne en a
acheté est ce que il ya quelque chose
que qu'on ne veut pas voir en france
c'est que dès la fin février début mars
vous n'aviez par exemple des entreprises
coréennes qui avait fabriqué plus de
tests elle en avait besoin qu'ils
proposaient leurs services aux
différents pays européens
ces mêmes entreprises ont été en contact
immédiat avec les ministres régionaux de
santé en allemagne et attendent toujours
la réponse du du ministère central de la
santé en france ou drs donc qui voulait
peut-être une différence et d'adaptation
de réaction à la crise ensuite il est
bien vrai que l'allemagne est un pays
qui est resté plus industrialisés que la
france deux fois plus industrialisés et
que pour cette raison là effectivement
l'allemagne a gardé beaucoup plus que
nous une mentalité industrielle donc la
capacité à penser les investissements de
long terme donc la capacité à mettre en
place une gestion de crise et donc aussi
la capacité à reconvertir les sites de
production par exemple les sites
industriels bade wurtemberg
ceci a fabriqué des respirateurs des
ventilateurs
qu'en est il du budget de la santé en
allemagne on accuse beaucoup les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés en
france d'avoir réduit les budgets des
hôpitaux publics alors qu'en est-il en
allemagne et qu'en est il du budget de
la recherche aussi on dit que cumuler le
budget de la recherche publique et de la
recherche privée il atteindrait 90
milliards d'euros en allemagne pour
seulement 50 milliards écoutez de deux
choses d'abord le
le budget de la santé est à peu près le
même dans les deux pays
doublement en cela par la part de
l'administration hospitalière est
l'illustration de la santé français 2 et
2 et 2 occupe à peu près un tiers du
budget concerné alors que en ces temps
20%
donc vous avez quelque chose qui est
évident c'est que l'allemagne a dépensé
mais pas pour la technostructure le
système de santé et pour un système
centralisé dirigé depuis la capitale
elle a investi dans les hôpitaux
et elle a mis en place une une techno
très légère pour la gouvernance du
système
donc effectivement l'allemagne était
capable de dégager d'emblée 28 lits de
réanimation quand la france en avait que
cinq mille à disposition au départ
aujourd'hui on a des outils
d'intelligence artificielle qui nous
aident à repérer à tracer nos traces
informatiques de façon assez intrusif et
assez précises mais il faudrait près il
faudrait déjà commencer à faire en sorte
que la législation le permettre cueillez
pas de difficulté à ce que les télécoms
transmettent à des autorités désignées
temporairement un certain nombre de
d'information qui permettrait de
retrouver ses contacts
aujourd'hui en europe c'est pas le cas
donc il faut juste pourquoi je dis ça
d'ailleurs c'est pas tellement pour
revenir sur l'épisode de cette première
vague qui nous est arrivé que tout le
monde essaye tant bien que mal
d'absorber dans de contrecarrer c'est
plutôt parce que si jamais une deuxième
vague devait se reproduire à l'automne
on va le savoir assez vite on pourra
expliquer comment on va le savoir mais
on devrait le savoir assez vite
aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas mais c'est
une option c'est un scénario et si une
vague revenait à l'automne elle pourrait
avoir exactement la même taille que
celle qui nous assaillent aujourd'hui
et là je pense que il n'est plus
question de mettre toute la population
au confinement ainsi que toutes les
économies au ralenti comme c'est le cas
je pense qu'on pour trouver les
meilleures solutions qui se sont
appliqués sur la terre aujourd'hui et
essayer de les
d adopter de les reproduire sans doute
de les adapter également parce que par
exemple il ya des nouveaux tests qui
arrive sur les anticorps qui viendront
compléter le dispositif
mais je pense pas qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui se dire non rien n'arrivera
plus c'est terminé on connaît la recette
on va faire du lock down up down la dame
je ne crois pas le continent c'est
provoquer une crise économique sans
précédent on sait pas ce que ça peut
donner
en mai 2009 il y avait une conférence
ten de données par bill gates qui
s'étonnait que l'on ne se prépare pas
convenablement à une bombe baby comme
auparavant
effectivement on s'était préparé une
attaque nucléaire le départ des troupes
dont j'avais on avait mis des moyens on
avait fait que les alliances
internationales tous à 8 semblait
nécessaire en vue du pays pandémie
mondiale dont il disait qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus de risques mais les champs
de mines afin que les cardinaux mort
dans une tour des médias que dans une
attaque nucléaire
on aurait voulu l'écouter et bill gates
mais je pense que le wild est si
l'écouté des gens comme nous sommes déjà
à l'époque non non je n'ai pas cette
prétention je pense que bill gate
justement à une vision qui est celle du
xxième siècle
le confinement strict c'est la vision du
début du 20e siècle on a un siècle de
retard
en appliquant des méthodes qui sont des
méthodes certes de distanciation social
mais on peut faire de la distanciation
social de précisions on peut
véritablement aller chercher les cas
suspects aujourd'hui parce qu'on a des
diagnostics moléculaires parce qu'on a
des diagnostic biologique qui nous
permet d'aller identifié au cas par cas
peut-être qu'il faut une petite armée et
de d'enquêteurs qui va aller chercher
ses contacts à domicile et exiger d'eux
un prélèvement pour qu'on puisse être
certain qu'ils soient qui te sont
négatifs ou au contraire si jamais ils
sont positifs pour qu'on leur demande et
qu'on exige d'eux et la loi reprendre
l'exemple de singapour
la loi est prévue dans ce cas très
particuliers ont peu de force
si la personne n'est pas d'accord sous
la contrainte on peut véritablement les
pelures de son foyer pendant une période
courte de quelques jours qui permet
véritablement de protéger les biens
portants et de d'augmenter cette
distance sociale d'une façon d'une eau
donc c'est pas non plus non autoritaire
on est dans quelque chose qui est très
intrusif mais qui respecte l'ensemble de
l'économie après on peut avoir un débat
démocratique qu'est ce que vous préférez
on est tous dans nos appartements sans
bouger et sans pouvoir travailler on
ferme tous les commerces tous les
marchés vont faire on gèle toute
l'économie du pays
ou bien on laisse tant que faire se peut
le maximum de cette économie vivre
normalement ou à peu près normalement
mais on accepte chacun que nos contacts
s'ils sont s'il s'avère être à risque
vont être provisoirement temporairement
des pistes et d'une part identifié mais
également accompagné d'un isolement que
l'on va consentir
ça c'est quelque chose que un pays
démocratique peut à mon avis de façon
claire décidé d'appliquer ou de ne pas
appliquer dans les premières phases de
l'épée en effet j'avais été frappé de
voir le nombre de tweets notamment de
personnalités politiques qui disent je
ne suis pas médecin mais je pense qu'il
faut faire ceci sous là où cela est
qu'ils disaient leur point de vue sur
quels traitements sur quelles mesures
préventives sur tel médicament même sans
rien y connaître et des sas là ça
illustre ayant l'important aujourd'hui
c'est au fil du temps à force de
recevoir des informations sur le petit
coronavirus on a compris que la sphère
était diablement compliqué que quand on
parle de test il faut s'entendre sur six
séries de tests virologiques ou
sérologique et c'est une affaire très
compliquée et donc on est un peu plus
prudent dans sa façon par les dessins
illustrent parfaitement un biais
cognitifs peu connue depuis très
longtemps mais qui a été baptisé
seulement en 1999 par deux psychologues
américains qui s'appelle downing et
kruger est c'est fait downing krueger
comme on l'appelle maintenant se résume
en un double paradoxe premier paradoxe
on ne peut savoir qu'on est incompétent
que si on est compétent donc c'est en
acquérant de la compétence
qu'on se rend compte qu'on est
incompétent mais au début on est sûr de
soi on découvre un nouveau champ assez
un virus ah bah c'est comme la grippe à
mâcher ce qu'il faut faire et c'est
seulement vous souvenez de la chanson
région de ghat peur quand on était
enfant je sais je sais il y à la fin de
sa vie il avait compris qu'on ne sait
jamais il avait acquis la table et
c'était une formule dix ans parce que je
ne suis pas médecin c'est là dessus que
je suis incompétent et donc c'est
honnête intellectuellement en admet qu
on est incompétent et ensuite on parle
comme un sachant et ça m'avait tellement
frappé que j'ai sur été résilié ce tract
est ce que montre l'effet downing
rigueur c'est que après quand on se met
à travailler on se rend compte qu'on est
incompétent donc on perd en assurance et
puis l'assurance que la confiance qu'on
a en soi remonte à mesure qu'on acquiert
des compétences et est ce qu'on a vu
pendant tout ce débat c'est que
certaines personnes très compétentes ont
parlé avec trop d'assurance parce
qu'elles ont utilisé des guerriers
recettes sur un problème qui était en
fait nouveau et donc on a on a assisté à
une sorte de jeu du chat et de la souris
à distance entre les incompétents qui
parle
et puis l'exception qui parlent trop
fort ou bien qu'ils se taisent enfin
bref ça a évolué aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que les choses se sont un
peu stabilisé c'est à dire que on attend
que les protocoles de recherche qui
demande un certain temps si on ne veut
pas abandonner tout méthodologie
finissent par livré leurs résultats mais
que ce n'est pas une affaire d'instinct
et je trouve que moi j'ai été surpris
par des déclarations par exemple de
donald trump qui est quand même un
champion du monde en matière de ultra
crépy d'ariane isme puisque lui il
invoque même pas son intuition pour
juger des choses et ce qu'il appelle son
instinct sais pas si vous avez vu ce
petit 08 10 un instinct du virus et
cette façon de régler les choses à
l'instinct c'est que de façon sous
jacente s'amène à considérer que ceux
qui réfléchissent ceux qui travaillent
ceux qui enquêtent
ceux qui doutent ce qui trompe qui se
trouve
parce qu'ils font des recherches
empreintes des détours qui sont à la
fois inutile et chronophage lui avec un
star n est pas directement au but et
gagne du temps par rapport aux 80 % des
sympathisants gilet jaune ème round on à
l'ars un attachement d'une population
qui est fragile qu'il a des difficultés
économiques qui est chauffé à blanc qui
a des difficultés financières
importantes parce que les gilets jaunes
sont souvent des gens qui sont des
petits indépendants qui n'ont pas un
salaire fixe et souvent des gens qui ont
des difficultés financières et qui ont
besoin de retravailler de façon urgente
donc il ya un désir d'avoir une solution
c'est terrible de ne pas avoir de
solution et puis raul tu as une figure
de sauveur et on voit que je ne compare
pas du tout didier raoul trap est un
mets dans l'attachement à didier raoul
ton retrouve les ressorts de l'adoration
des français à l'été 40 pour pétain la
figure paternelle rassurante
le druide les racines françaises le
sauveur il y a là un retour à
l'attachement au chef au sauveur
il ya une dimension quasi religieuse je
suis assez actif sur twitter
et ce qui me vaut de recevoir quelques
milliers de messages d'insultés par jour
parce que je ne suis pas tellement pros
raul tu es je vois la détresse des gens
les gens pensent que quand on est anti
raul ton est un assassin les gens sont
sincèrement persuadés que la chloroquine
soigné et guéri la quasi-totalité des
malades
ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi faut
faire des essais cliniques les chiffres
qui ont été habilement manipulé par
didier raoul qu ils ne savent pas les
lire et les interpréter ils n'ont pas
bien compris que didier raoul tu as
récupéré des malades très jeune très peu
graves qui ont fait la queue pendant
plusieurs heures devant lier achu ya
aucun obèses quand on regarde les photos
des gens qui l'a inclus dans ses études
il ya personne avec un déambulateur ya
aucun vieillard il ya aucun n'y a pas de
malades chroniques et le score de
gravité des patients qui l'a inclus est
extrêmement faible
73 9% ou encore new skies et qui mesure
la gravité des malades qui est à 0 ce
sont des gens comme vous et moi
donc oui dédié raul n'a en apparence des
chiffres formidable mais qui
correspondent au fait qu'il a récupéré
des malades qui n'était pas vraiment
malade
c'est d'ailleurs ce que remarque de
façon acerbe l'après scientifique
internationale qui commence à se
de la gueule de l' expertise française
parce que ces méthodologies sont
inacceptables et et les experts
internationaux rigole 1 alors bien sûr
didier raoul tu as eu la chance d'avoir
son idée récupéré par donald trump
parce que donald trump en regardant sa
chaîne favorite complotistes et plein de
fake news fox news s'est dit tout d'un
coup ça va éviter qu'on fasse du
confinement aux états unis et ça va
garantir ma réélection à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
c'est comme ça que didier raoul tu es
devenu une icône mondiale des
complotistes et et des populistes
mais moi je ne me mets pas du tout des
gens qui qui qui aiment et qu'ils
admirent à ault même s'ils m'insultent
beaucoup beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux
ces gens sont vraiment désemparés et ils
ont l'impression qu'on leur cache
quelque chose et ils adhèrent à
n'importe quelle thèse complotiste
d'ailleurs quand le professeur
montagnier à la télé la semaine dernière
a annoncé qu' on avait incorporé des
morceaux du virus du sida
intentionnellement dans le virus de
covin 19 et que les antennes 5g
favorisait la diffusion de la maladie
beaucoup de gens y ont cru alors que ses
propos sont des propos délirants en
venant d'un homme qui ne va pas très
bien et dont déjà en 2017 le figaro
traitait à son sujet le naufrage du
professeur montagnier
mais la plupart des gens qui croient en
raul tu crois aussi en montagne et et
ils ont l'impression qu'il ya un complot
pour faire tes raul pour faire taire ma
montagne et ce n'est pas spécifique à la
france il y a eu des vidéos complotistes
en angleterre qui prétendait que les
antennes 5g favorisait là encore le
corona virus et il y as en angleterre
deux antennes 5 g qui sont détruites
chaque jour par des gens qui ont peur
d'attraper le kobe de 19
donc cette pensée complotistes très
inquiète elle se diffuse elle est
inquiète elle et elle est inquiétante
c'est un vrai recul de la science est un
vrai
recul delà de la rationalité et les
hommes politiques n'ont pas toujours été
très sage beaucoup de leaders politiques
notamment à droite
je ne parle pas du rassemblement
national ont soutenu à mort didier
rahout je ne sais pas si c'est par
calcul politique aussi il y croyait beau
vraiment mais en tout cas ils n'ont pas
été raisonnable et ils ont poussé
l'opinion publique à penser que le
ministre était méchant de refuser la
généralisation du protocole raul tu
alors qu'en réalité le ministre de la
santé olivier derand a eu une position
extrêmement sage par rapport aux
cocktails par rapport à la position à
août et le 22 23 mars les stocks de
chloroquine disponible au maroc ont été
réquisitionnés par l'état et donc qu'il
s'agisse du plach nil ou du nivaquine
sert de la chloroquine ou dick hydroxy
chloroquine vous ne pouvez plus et
acheter en pharmacie parce que l'état
eric avec et visionner tous les stocks
ont vue de d'établir un protocole pour
soigner les gens qui arrivent au niveau
des centres de santé publique
donc effectivement fait une bithérapie
qui a été appliquée au maroc très tôt
qui afin qu'ils intègrent hydroxy
chloroquine et l'azithromycine est un
antibiotique puis le pulmonaire et qui
comment dire qu'il met en avant le fait
que le maroc n'est pas tombé dans le
piège des luttes idéologiques et des
conflits d'intérêts que la france a
connu c'est que on a le choix entre deux
choses on a le choix entre la bithérapie
tpo proposé par didier raoult ou bien
rien j'ai la face à rien face à la mort
la bithérapie s'avère prometteuse
donc après il faut comprendre qu'au
niveau de la recherche anorienne la
logique de protocoles de recherche qui
effectivement une temporalité de longue
durée avant d'aboutir à une autorisation
une législation
et puis à la réalité du médecin qui en
l'occurrence sur le terrain n'est pas un
chercheur et qui est confronté à une
réalité immédiate à des gens qu'on crée
et qui doit chercher dans l'arsenal
qu'il possède les molécules ancienne et
connue qui peuvent aider le patient à
guérir et donc en réalité au maroc on
n'est pas allé contre la recherche mais
on a plutôt favorisé ce qu'on appelle la
médecine observationnelles désir qui
parle du terrain de la réalité pour
soigner les gens efficacement et les
résultats sont très intéressants au
maroc
c'est qu'on va que le maroc a adopté le
protocole vers le 22 mars
et dès le 9 avril on voit un décrochage
des morts cumulés quand on voit la cour
elle s'aplatit donc il ya de moins en
moins deux morts et on voit le cas de
guérison qui décolle littéralement temps
parce que pendant très longtemps durant
deux mois de mars on avait un rapport
entre les décès cumulée et les guérisons
cumulé qui était très très proches ont
été littéralement dans un bras de fer et
puis tout d'un coup il ya un décalage
extrêmement rapide et ça coïncide entre
autres avec l'introduction de la
bithérapie tel que proposé par le
professeur didier raoult
parce que là encore en france on connaît
très bien les conflits d'intérêts entre
but vint levitin côté fan au monde de
l'autre et puis didier raoult de l'autre
il ya des gens qui veulent absolument un
vaccin pour pouvoir le vendre à à coups
de milliards à l'échelle planétaire par
des commandes publiques tandis que
manivelle tandis que la chloroquine qui
ne coûte pas cher et quand même embêtant
pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
d'autant plus que les résultats risquent
d'être surprenant quand on va obtenir
des résultats appuyé et on ne voit très
bien la plupart des études qui ont été
commandées par l'état français vont tous
testés sorte la bithérapie de 10 des
roms ils vont tester soi l'hydroxyde
dorking tout seul soit la chloroquine
tout seul mais jamais les deux donc lui
il ya une guerre contre la chloroquine
est contrefaite bithérapie donc le maroc
là encore à des preuves de réalisme il a
opté pour le choix le plus réaliste et
le plus efficace et heureusement on est
en train de voir une amélioration de la
situation au maroc après les chiffres et
plus donc quand on parle des cas
confirmés au maroc c'est conditionné par
la capacité de dépistage
qu'effectivement le maroc n'a pas les
moyens de mettre en place des dépistage
massif comme en allemagne
parce qu'au total en a fait depuis le
début de la pandémie environ 28 est ce
qui n'est rien en réalité
mais par contre ce qui est tangible
c'est le cas de décès d'accord on peut
pas tricher et le cas de guérison et là
par contre effectivement les résultats
sont très satisfaisants et très
encourageant mais il est évident que si
on élargit le dépistage on obtiendra
beaucoup plus de cas confirmés mais la
majorité sont symptomatiques
[Musique]
le principal enseignement de l'épidémie
pour vous c'est que les métiers les plus
importants ne sont pas ceux que l'on
croyait absolument ce qu'on se dise qui
nous sautent à la figure aujourd'hui
c'est que les métiers les plus
importants ce sont des métiers qui
jusqu'à maintenant était invisible était
déconsidérée était très souvent
rassemblés sous la catégorie d'emplois
non qualifiés et étaient parmi les
métiers les plus mal payés et
principalement occupés par des femmes
voilà toutes les caractéristiques des
métiers qui aujourd'hui sont en première
ligne pour assurer notre survie et pour
assurer les fonctions je dirais les
toutes les fonctions essentielles à la
vie en société
2000 pédales c'est sûr que ces métiers
sont essentiels on en a la preuve tous
les jours mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'on ne les trouvez pas essentiel
auparavant et et en cas d incendie c'est
sûr qu'on a tendance à trouver
l'essentiel le métier de pompier mais
une fois que l'incendié est éteint
on appelle son avocat on appelle son
assureur et on oublie les pompiers tout
à fait mais vous serez d'accord avec moi
pour dire que on parle quand même
vraiment pas souvent des aides
soignantes ou des auxiliaires de vie
celle qui vont tous les jours pour faire
la toilette et donner à manger aux
personnes âgées
vous m'avez aurait aussi que quand on
parle aux petites filles souvent on leur
dit que devenir caissière
c'est pas génial donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est un ensemble de
métiers qui dans notre société n'ont
aucun prestige sont déconsidérés et sont
également mal pays et que pourtant
aujourd'hui ce sont vraiment les métiers
sur lesquels passant dès qu'elles ont
des mourets tout simplement alors
peuvent tout un ensemble les métiers
qu'on appelle du caire donc j'ai dit
elle soigne en auxiliaires de vie etc
tous les métiers de la grande
distribution mais évidemment aussi
l'habiter de la production à des
agriculteurs tous ceux qui nous
permettent tout simplement les fonctions
minimales c'est se nourrir se soigner et
vous pourriez acheter les fermiers des
fonctions de nettoiement
nettoyage public c'est évidemment
primordial par les temps qui courent ce
qui devrait être remise en cause dit
vous c'est l'heure sous rémunération par
rapport à des métiers valoriser qui
aujourd'hui ont pratiquement disparu des
radars pour cause et sont au chômage de
publicitaire avocat fiscaliste on me
dire ça ou encore je dirais consultant
new public management
ces personnes qui sont les grands
cabinets et qui sont en partie pardonnez
moi je dis quelque chose qui est assez
fort je j'en ai conscience mais qui nous
ont quand même en partie amené à la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve par
exemple ce sont eux qui ont conseillé
les hôpitaux pour passer d'un hôpital de
stock un hôpital de flux ce sont eux qui
ont relayé tous les messages du
consensus de washington du
néolibéralisme trop dépenses publiques
il faut tout mettre vers le privé le new
public management lorsqu'il ça avait de
pire
je pense que tous ces gens là continue à
travailler je crois d'ailleurs que l'on
a beaucoup dans les allées du pouvoir
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des designs des
ses fiches de crise et je pense que ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose que nous
devrions parler tous ensemble qui est
très très présent lieu parce que ça
continue comme avant et il risque de
nous entraîner à continuer comme pour le
gouvernement le plus important c'est que
l'économique 104 totalement à l'arrêt
vous comprenez oui je le comprends bien
dans le même temps il me semble que la
priorité des priorités aujourd'hui c'est
pas tellement celle-ci malheureusement
c'est la priorité sanitaire
c'est à dire que l'hôpital public en
france a subi depuis des années on sait
bien maintenant des réductions de
budgets publics draconiennes on voit
aujourd'hui que l'austérité budgétaire
ça tue tout simplement
donc si les françaises et les français
qui meurent aujourd'hui c'est aussi et
d'abord parce que l'hôpital public n'a
plus les moyens de travailler
correctement depuis des années ça c'est
le premier qu'on l'ait donc là mon avis
l'urgence des urgences aujourd'hui c'est
un investissement public massif de
manière à permettre à l'hôpital de
limiter la casse un achat massif de
machines à ventiler de matériel médical
pour permettre de sauver des vies
maintenant maintenant il me semble que
c'est la priorité des priorités la
deuxième c
de permettre aux françaises et aux
français de sortie en confirmant le
confinement comme tels ne résout pas le
problème
le confinement permet juste à partir du
moment où on a raté le coche initial qui
était le dépistage systématique
ce qu'a fait la corée du sud ce capital
one ce que nous aurions dû faire a
partiellement ou non nous n'avons pas
fait sérieusement nous avons laissé le
virus se répand dans la population
lorsque les autorités publiques se sont
réveillés c'était trop tard donc à ce
moment là la seule option viable c'est
elle qu'on filme en ce que nous avons
fait il est également trop tard
maintenant le confinement lui-même ne
stoppe pas l'épidémie
c'est à dire que si demain matin tout le
monde ressort de son domicile ça
recommence l'épidémie et reprend de plus
belle avec en plus un système
hospitalier qui est déjà à genoux donc
la question c'est à partir du moment où
on va sortir du confinement pratiquer le
dépistage le plus systématique possible
pour faire ce qu'on aurait dû faire
au tout début la stratégie sud-coréenne
de la stratégie taïwanaise qui ont
réussi pour l'instant à refouler la
pandémie sans confinement
donc ça veut dire que la durée le
confirme en tout cas c'est une question
que beaucoup d'entre nous se posent la
durée du confinement elle est liée
essentiellement à notre capacité à faire
des tests
donc les deux facteurs limitants ce sont
deux enzymes qu'il faut produire à toute
vitesse pour faire des tests en masse
j'avais millions test
une fois qu'on aura produit ces enzymes
capables de le faire à laboratoire
français en train de le faire alors il
faudra s'organiser de manière à faire du
dépistage systématique de manière que
les français puissent sortir de
l'enfermement
si on ne fait pas ça soit on reste
confinée et on attend qu'il y une
immunisation collective à l'intérieur du
confinement
ce qui semble devenir la stratégie d'un
certain nombre de zones par exemple aux
états unis mais des petits calculs de
coin de table montre dans ce cas là on
en a pour six mois de confinement
je pense que c'est intenable à la fois
économiquement financièrement
socialement psychologiquement pour la
plupart trouvent donc il faut sortir
bien avant il faut sortir le plus vite
possible du confinement
aussi pour permettre à l'économie de
redémarrer mais la seule condition la
condition majeure pour sortir de
confinement c'est de pratiquer le
dépistage
ce que les médecins chinois ne cesse de
répéter depuis début sûr que l' oms ne
cesse de répéter également mais nous
n'avons pas écouté
c'est à dire des pistes et de manière à
ensuite remettre non pas en quarantaine
mais en 14 n 14 jours les personnes qui
sont qui sont positives et puis
permettre aux autres de retravailler de
mener une vie sociale normale
et puis évidemment une distribution de
masques massines à tous de manière à
limiter la diffusion du virus
lorsque nous seront sortis et
malheureusement on en a pour au moins un
an de bagua avec ce virus sur la
totalité de la planète
un rapport de l'administration
américaine qui fait état de probablement
18 mois donc ça me dire qu'il y aura des
deuxième vague
il faudra probablement reconfirmer
certaine partie de la population
mais voilà ça va être notre quotidien
pendant un an et demi le plusieurs
genres mon avis pour l'instant étant de
sauver des vies dans les hôpitaux et de
préparer la sortie est la plus rapide
possible du confinement via le dépistage
systématique dans le domaine de la santé
nous manque à ses clients aujourd'hui
dans un pays comme la france
alors est ce que c'est le résultat de la
réduction des budgets publics ou comme
vous auriez peut-être tendance à penser
de la gratuité générale des soins à lui
je crois que les les deux sont un peu
lié c'est à dire que à partir du moment
où la santé publique a été pilotée par
la gratuité on a forcément la mise en
place d'un système de rationnement et un
ajustement par la baisse de la qualité
des soins et il a encore je pense qu'on
n'a pas suffisamment réfléchi ce qu'on
vend aux etats-unis c'est-à-dire le fait
qu' il est très important qu'il y ait
une couverture universelle de la
population et ça c'est important
évidemment pour les individus mais aussi
pour la santé publique
à la vérité que tout soit gratuit pour
tout le monde et pour tous les soins
ça c'est une idée qui n'a aucun sens sur
le plan de la santé qui n'a aucun sens
sur le plan de la solidarité qui n'a
aucun sens sur le plan économique
et c'est vrai que cette politique de
rationnement ont entraîné une baisse de
la qualité une baisse de la qualité des
soins
et une organisation des soins sur le
mode de la pénurie
c'est aussi ce qui explique par exemple
cette aberration qui a été la
suppression des stocks stratégiques de
masques puisqu'en 2012 on avait encore
plus d'un milliard de masques en stock
et que ce stock a été réduit à 145
millions au début de la crise qui
explique que très rapidement on se soit
retrouvé dans une situation de pénurie
criante et que parce qu'on n'avait pas
de mac
on a prétendu qu'il n'était pas utile ce
qui est évidemment et malheureusement un
casque est faux alors sur le plan
politique maintenant j'en reviens à
atholville qui doutaient consacré à liv
les reproché à la france sa
centralisation son inflation législative
des moyens efficaces et inappliquée
qu'on remplace par des lois plus
contraignantes encore mais pas plus
appliqué il
il résume l salle de la façon suivante
une règles rigides et une pratique molle
ils reprochaient également les emplois
réservés les très bons décidé pur
l'égoïsme de classe de la classe
dominante en particulier l'immobilité
sociales et politiques
alors là aussi sur le plan politique
qu'est ce que cette crise du corps des
virus nous apprend je crois que la
france
le corps navires us et pour la france
comme pour tous les pays développés un
test impitoyable pour les institutions
et pour les dirigeants donc c'est une
crise majeure on va voir sans doute
malheureusement aux états unis que le
système américain aura réagi encore plus
sans doute de manière plus inefficace et
dangereuse que la plupart des pays
d'europe
pour la france on retrouve le point de
croisement entre donc cette crise sans
précédent même si d'ailleurs taux de
ville a connu la l'épidémie de choléra
de 1832 c'est pour cette raison qu'il
est revenue des états unis parce qu'il
était inquiet pour sa famille et donc on
retrouve
cette parenthèse une crise générale mais
un certain nombre de traverses français
que tocqueville avait pointé pour
expliquer le cours particulièrement
portée de notre histoire
il ya d'abord une très grande
centralisation le fait que la nation
s'est créé autour de l'état il y a donc
également un très grand individualiste
un très grand individualisme et puis il
appelle la faiblesse de la société
civile entre les deux puisque l'état
qu'il soit benard chic ou
révolutionnaire a toujours poursuivi et
cherchait à obtenir la suppression des
cordes intermédiaire
aujourd'hui il est vrai que les pays qui
gère le mieux c'est que krine souvent
sont des pays qui ont su s'appuyer aussi
sur la mobilisation de la population par
alain initiative évidemment des états
mais avec des forts système de
solidarité donc on retrouve comme
toujours à la fois les traits d'une
grande crise qui dépasse la france comme
les guerres du xxème siècle où les
grandes crises économiques dépassent
notre pays et en même temps un certain
nombre de pathologies française qu'il
contribue à expliquer notre manque de
réactivité
de ce point de vue là c'est vrai que l'
extrême centralisation du pouvoir est en
est une difficulté
je note d'ailleurs à ce propos qu' on a
du coup à l'occasion de cette crise
créer un nouveau régime de circonstances
exceptionnelles avec la loi d'urgence
sanitaire qui prévoit d'aider des
pouvoirs notamment des pouvoirs de
réquisition confié au milieu de la santé
sans aucun contrôle et qui sont à la
fois exorbitantes du droit commun est
très préoccupant du point de vue des
libertés est la fin du cradat virus vous
prévoyez que la chine restera seul
debout
sur le plan économique un peu comme les
états unis à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale d'ailleurs alors pourquoi la
chine pensez-vous date est le mieux
résisté que les autres parce que parce
que la chine n'est pas dévasté parce que
la chine est la chine a su contenir
cette épidémie parce que sur les quais
son économie effectivement n'a pas
inclus un coup mais on va voir dans quel
état seront new lows économie en europe
dans quel état sera l'économie
américaine à la sorte et à la sortie de
ça en espérant que la sortie vienne
vienne vienne bientôt et c'est pour ça
que j'ai utilisé ce chai en 44 quand on
fait tous les comptes le seul pays qui
apparemment pas été en guerre sur son
propre territoire d'une manière ou d'une
autre l'allemagne bien sûr envahi envahi
les autres mais après elle a été envoyée
par le par la suite à la fin de la
guerre quand on refait les comptes
les états unis représentent 75% de
l'économie mondiale je serais pas étonné
que au sortir de la crise au jeu c'est
pas l'automne si tout se passe bien
quand on fera les comptes d'une itt des
économies qui sont en état de
fonctionnement connaît un chiffre par le
même chiffre pour la chine que la chine
représente 75 % de l'économie mondiale
je serais pas étonné il pays qui
souffrira le plus douces ce sont les
états unis alors pourquoi les états unis
pour que souffrir et qu'il davantage que
les économies européennes par exemple le
pays sont sont unifiés d'une certaine
manière ne sont pas des confédérations
nous avons été des confédérations la la
la bretagne sud où je vous parle ce
n'était pas exactement là la france à la
même époque la bourgogne essaie de créer
un état indépendant
il y avait des anglais quelque part du
côté de la clietèle etc mais nous avons
nous avons intégré les états même la
belgique même la pj qu'avec sont ceux de
fédéralisme est un pupille intégré il ya
une direction fédérale
or qu'est ce qui est arrivé depuis là
depuis que trump eto'o est aux manettes
il essaye de tricoter entièrement les
l'état l'état fédéral et il y a une
grande agence qui s'appelle à la finma
qui s'occupe des grandes catastrophes
états unis mais il a mis à la tête de
toutes ces agences de type fédéral des
gens et des anciens lobbyistes des
choses qu'on essaie de contrôler il me
dit pas des globules lobis la tête de
qui ont été à la tête du delage
l'énergie des de l'énergie pétrolière
ils l'aiment à la tête de
l'environnement et les choses comme ça
il a saboté entièrement le système et je
parle même pas parce que c'est pas
d'actualité mais le fait qu'elle remplit
remplace tous les juges par des juges
extrême droite en ce moment
non c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà fait un
extrême boulot de deux de sabotage de
l'état fédéral aux états unis sur lequel
tout le monde compte alors on lui on
vient lui donner des pouvoirs à trump
depuis trois-quatre jours des pouvoirs
de 2 qui lui permettrait de mobiliser
entièrement l'appareil fédéral
ils bougent pas ils bougent pas il dit
oui les entreprises selon son type de
raisonnement les entreprises privées
vont intervenir et on a vu ce que ça
donne les entreprises privées qui oblige
les le royaume uni avec un gouvernement
johnson qui est pas particulièrement de
de gauche à nationaliser ce matin le
lait tous les chemins de fer une
politique de confinement assortie d'une
répression que je trouve moins
personnellement quasiment obscène
infliger des amendes de qui vont jusqu'à
3500 euros à des gens qui qui qui gagne
qui sont peut-être au rsa et qui empoche
plus qu'ils sont en train de devenir
dingue dans le confinement et qui vont
essayer de prendre l'air d'accord une
telle violence une telle férocité
jusqu'à des peines de prison ferme et
c'est alors que dans le même temps on
oblige d'aller au travail que les photos
du métro parisien gare du nord à 6
heures du matin montrent des quais
bondés montre des gens à touche-touche
d'accord qu'est ce qu'ils racontent ce
gouvernement qu'est ce qui nous dit il
oblige les gens à aller travailler à
paris à 14 millions d'habitants dans un
métro bondé mais il fait surveiller les
plages du finistère par des hélicoptères
dans des excuses mais il a marqué il
marque et du coup sur mon front enfin je
veux dire
cc c'est quoi le truc je lis à quel
moment jusqu'à combien de temps va se
de notre gueule avec ce truc là
je veux dire ce soit il ya un problème
de confinement et on confine soit on
peut envoyer tout le monde bosse et dans
le métro et faut arrêter d'emmerder le
monde parce qu'ils vont prendre l'air
sur une plage donc ce que ce que ce qui
me met la puce à l'oreille c'est là je
le disais tout à l'heure c'est l'âme
la violence de cette répression la
férocité de 7
pression sur des histoires de promenade
ça ça ne va pas le coup de l'hélicoptère
et je trouve extrêmement symptomatique
enfin je veux dire c'est c'est là encore
vous avez un test en grandeur nature qui
est un test de l'obéissance de la police
est ce que la police va les cent
soixante mille personnes mobilisées
est-ce qu'ils vont accepter cette cette
politique de répression
c'est un test est ce qu'on va trouver un
gendarme assez avec suffisamment de
neurones dans la tête pour conduire un
hélicoptère au dessus d'une plage pour
traquer une petite vieille qui va
respirer oui manifestement au trou donc
il ya un vrai test en grandeur nature de
contrôle d'une population avec une
répression plus rentable mais qui
s'adresse sur du plaisir de la détente
d'accord mais pas le travail le travail
faut aller bosser par contre par contre
se détendre ça c'est pas bien ça c'est
là vous avez une moralisation du
problème enfin c'est un sens et une aux
stratégies de la langue de bois c'est
les statistiques sais pas si vous vous
connaissez peut-être la blague 98 98 %
des gens croient une statine une
information si elles contiennent
statistiques
en fait cette communication sur les
médias dominants sur france 2 ou autre
elle tourne en boucle sur trois
informations qui sont chaque jour de
nous annoncer un nombre de décès qui
plie plus grand que la veille sans que
ces décès ne soit jamais rapporté à rien
c'est à dire que moi me dire il ya 400
morts
ça peut être très effrayant que ça peut
l'être pas tellement si on met en regard
d'autres chiffres mais ok reconnaissez
franck lepage qu'elle si au moment où on
apprend que plus de mille personnes sont
mortes dans les ehpad depuis le début du
confinement si on disait bros et pas
grand chose par rapport aux 80 ou 100
mille morts habituel chaque année ça
choquerait tout le monde vous compris et
moi compris non oui c'est juste que ces
chiffres ne sont pas éclairés et je peux
rien faire avec un chiffre pareil quand
on me dit j'ai regardé les chiffres en
bretagne j'habite en bretagne on est à
88 morts bon la dernière fois que
j'avais regardé c'est la semaine
dernière on était à 32 morts ok 32 morts
de 32 à 88 c'est moche c'est vraiment
pas terrible 80 humeur il ya trois eu
trois millions et demi de personnes en
bretagne s'est excusé moi mais enfin je
veux dire 88 morts sur trois millions et
demi de personnes
est ce que c'est un chiffre inquiétant
j'en sais rien je ne peux pas analysé ce
chiffre cette question des chiffres et
les ailes et extrêmement perturbantes
parce que à la fois c'est une
information qui est angoissante
ces acquis à une hystérisation du
problème on nous annonce des nombres de
morts mais en même temps si on met ces
chiffres on regarde d'autres chiffres ça
devient ça devient presque bizarre c'est
ses 73 mille mans du tabac chaque année
en france elle est mort dans les ehpad
ses 400 par jour normalement enfin vous
savez on est on est on nous a parlé de
la grippe saisonnière tout ça leur
faisait toujours des gens qui disent non
l'on peut pas comparer on peut toujours
comparer l'intérêt de la comparaison
c'est précisément de mettre des choses
qui sont pas qu'ils sont qui sont pas
les mêmes donc voilà donc sur cette
communication par les chiffres
je sais pas quoi vous dire je suis
vraiment perplexe ce que j'ai décidé si
d'arrêter d'écouter les informations
parce que c'est terrible c'est
complètement angoissant pour moi je le
dis tel que je pense je pense que les
intellectuels qui se précipitent sur
cette crise pour essayer de l'avoir
comme quelque chose dont ils se
réjouissent presque si je trouve sa
répulsion que les gens qui vont dire on
va réapprendre à vivre autrement on va
réapprendre la vie simple on va sortir
de la syriza de la foulée néolibérale a
certes ça tout ça les gens qui essaient
de plaquer leur dise
or anciens sur cette maladie pour
essayer de faire comme c'était une
maladie ce n est qu en vérité ce serait
l'humanité qui serait malade qui serait
le virus qui serait dégénérescente et
que ce virus c'est comme une manière de
refaire un peu de santé
pour moi c'est vraiment les discours les
plus répugnants et qui montre d'ailleurs
à mon avis l'humeur l'extrême droite
isation et le chêne de pensée fasciste
que la civilisation est malade et que le
virus est une santé c'est vraiment un
chef de penser complètement répugnant
surtout quand on s'imagine que la
naissance de d'épidémie comme ça c'est
dans les marchés alimentaires dits
sionnel les animaux sauvages originaux
qui aura plutôt à des pratiques
traditionnelles de la paysannerie pas
tellement à des choses qui aura que le
néolibéralisme jimmy stade de new york 1
sept années à new york ses yeux et donc
moi franchement je trouve qu'il ya une
une pente qui veulent toujours dénoncé
ces chercher du sens à la mallette
chercher du sens aux catastrophes
sanitaires ou aux catastrophes comme les
gens m'ont fait le sida qui était une
des choses les plus récurrents que je
recherchais du sens aux sea dogs c'était
une punition pour les homos c'est bel et
bien aussi pour les marginaux pour les
travailleurs du sexe et c'est là il ya
un peu le même trahi le mood que moi je
trouve particulièrement répugnant nadine
apathie danse mais invite un accident
naturel maladie arrive elle peut se
combattre et peut se gérer mais elle n'a
pas de sens un cas pas de signification
historique et tous les gens qui se
précipitent la typo et donner du sens ce
sont des vins pour moi c'est vraiment le
contraire de la santé intellectuelle de
facile pourquoi est-ce que ça toucherait
semble-t-il en grande majorité des
hommes à l'exception peut-être du québec
qu'au québec on remarque que plus de
femmes figurent parmi les cas confirmés
à 60% je crois et même parmi les 17 à
54% des femmes notamment du personnel
soignant d'ailleurs mais sinon en france
notamment ce sont surtout des hommes
alors pourquoi alors déjà parce que
probablement on a bien protégé nos
personnels soignants je dis ça c'est
important cette car vous avez tout à
fait raison lorsqu'il ya une très forte
probabilité proportion de femmes dans
une maladie infectieuse respiratoires
généralement la raison est que le
personnel soignant a été mal protégés ça
a été le cas du strass on a tenu
on a tiré les leçons du strass en le
strass c'était en 2003 c'était aussi un
coronavirus aussi respiratoires et qui
entraînait des pneumonies
en sévère au début on a été tellement
surpris par le sera ce que les premiers
hôpitaux qui ont eu à prendre en charge
ces cas ne se sont pas suffisamment
équipés ne se sont pas suffisamment
protégés
et puis on a vu du reste à l'occasion du
strass en particulier des études de
singapour montré que les personnels
soignants lorsqu'il mettait des masques
de protection étaient très très très
bien protégés et c'était ça qu'il
fallait faire et après les gens l'ont
fait mais du coup les premiers la
proportion de femmes dans le strass est
beaucoup beaucoup plus importante que
dans le corps nasco vide 19 donc je
pense que dans le cockpit 19
le fait qu'ils aient moins de femmes est
un bon reflet de la précaution compris
les soignants pour se protéger
maintenant pourquoi ce n'est pas à
égalité
c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
compliqué et difficile à répondre parce
que non seulement les femmes sont plutôt
moins souvent atteintes que des hommes
mais en plus les femmes sont moins de
complications
les hommes être une jeune femme
aujourd'hui vous soustrait pratiquement
du risque de complications en
particulier de complications fatale du
coc vite pas totalement malheureusement
on doit déplorer quelques décès chez des
femmes aussi
mais les femmes semblent très protégé
sans qu'on en sache vraiment la raison
alors il faut savoir que les femmes
vivent plus longtemps que les hommes et
que on a même pu montrer il ya vu des
études qui ont montré un niveau très
très égal de socio culturel et de
travail par exemple qu'on me prenait des
bonnes soeurs et des moines de bonnes
soeurs vivent un peu plus longtemps que
les moines donc il semble que le sexe
protège le sexe féminin protègent contre
beaucoup de maladies et visiblement il a
l'air de protéger aussi contre le corps
d'un virus ce qui est une particularité
qui est pas encore à moins à mon sens
totalement expliquée et les enfants
alors puisque sacré une
grande polémique en france sur demande
la réouverture des écoles faut-il
envoyer ses enfants à l'école ou pas que
sait-on aujourd'hui du cas des enfants
alors comme vous défendez dans la
polémique mais aussi dans la controverse
scientifique c'est à dire que le cas des
enfants n'est pas totalement clarifiée
aujourd'hui alors ça doit être un peu
pénible à entendre le fait qu'on ait des
hésitations des départs fois des
retournements quand on est scientifique
mais il faut comprendre que dans ces
maladies tout à fait nouvelle le
chapitre n'est pas écrit et il s'écrit
un peu sous nos yeux et jusqu'à présent
on sait qu' il ya une sorte de paradoxe
qu'il faut relever on sait que les
enfants sont moins souvent atteints dans
les statistiques on voit moins d'enfants
que d'adultes de façon très claire c'est
à dire que que ce soit les données
venant de chine où les données venant
d'europe et des états unis désormais on
a beaucoup beaucoup moins d'enfants
parmi l'ensemble des cas qui nous sont
rapportés pour vous dire pour la grippe
plus de 50 % des cas sont des enfants
pour le coc vide c'est pas du tout le
cas ces quelques pourcents c'est très
très très marginale donc clairement les
enfants semblent moins je dirais pas
forcément porteur du virus on va revenir
là dessus mais en tout cas moins souvent
il exprime des signes de la maladie qui
les amène à consulter et à se faire
tester et à se faire repérer comme
porteurs du virus pourrait se dire aussi
que ce nouvel ennemi invisible
le chi chi et le coronel virus pourrait
aussi tous nous nous réconcilier
certains disaient que pour que les
peuples sur terre se réconcilient il
faudrait une invasion extraterrestre ben
là on a on alcohol daa virus ce ne sont
pas des extra ce n'est pas un
extraterrestre mais mais au fond on se
sont tous solidaires les êtres humains
face à lui
c'est ce qu'il aurait dû faire le
coronavirus parce que le coronavirus
nous a montré que la mondialisation
économique aux techniques qui s'est
produite à créer de l'interdépendance
incontestable mais que l'interdépendance
n'a créé aucune solidarité et que à ce
moment là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'absence de solidarité c'est que quand
arrive le virus et des épidémies
chaque état national se referme sur
lui-même
alors que nous sommes en même temps
conscient que c'était une maladie
planétaire qui fera toute l'humanité
mais nous avons faute aussi bien d'une
conscience collective humaine niveau
planétaire aussi bien lieu de
organisation capable comme le lot et
metz l'onu de coordonner les efforts
différence on se réfugie dans l'égoïsme
national et même le pour l'europe on est
très en retard et même pour l'europe
le problème n'était pas de se refermer
sur un égoïsme européen le problème
était d'avoir une solidarité européenne
je pense que c'est très bien qu'il y ait
cette solidarité nationale et cet appel
international ce serait pas mal heureux
mais il ya aussi une solidarité humaine
on devrait comprendre aujourd'hui le
virus nous donner tous nié on est tous
inséparables on est bon on doit s'unir
et on n'écoute pas la leçon du virus
[Musique]